pppt pppt pppt
hi everyone it's not like my Hardy and
this is Lipton gilgamesh a good friend
of mine
we've been playing through all the
Resident Evil's for about I don't know I
just took to Lipton Gilgamesh nice to
see you as always on this fine Saturday
whether you're on whatever part of the
world
no I was talking there are viewers okay
see you um I just kidding I know you
were not feeling well this week neither
was I so much coming from this side of
the tape right so Lipton we were both
really sick this week I was sick
Wednesday I was a two-barrel day so got
a little bit of a t-virus going on I
like don't know what happened to me but
I haven't been so we got that black bar
here whoops what happened oh just move
it over oh that's on that side okay you
get the point you want Lipton to fix it
hey Lipton it's perfect
hell yeah good they're seeing behind
they're seeing how the sausages seasoned
it's right it's me okay sweet we're back
so you got you picked up the firewater
motif key last time so that's what we
want to do now and then you're moving
your items did the water tea key am i
nuts let's
alright let me just look here I thought
I really did it yeah cuz I don't have
the key anymore okay cool yeah well no
were you going through the doors that
used oh you did all the stuff with the
hunters you got I got a new key from him
which led you pass the wet room or
whatever it's called and that like silo
upstairs yes but I don't remember what
our goal is for this week she's a girl
my gym I
oh right we moved all the stuff remember
we basically on the behest of comments
which I hope her accurate we were like
let's move Gooden I think we're the
second half of the game here I can pull
up the map here we moved all of our [ __ ]
into this circle yeah and then we did
all of the water rooms which were gray
and now they're not and honest to god
you you uh you should have all the
tablets right do i I think so I know I
have to I don't you already put one in
and the other one may or may be we have
to get the last one right I think we
have to get the last one
but I'm willing to discuss that with you
because oh yeah no no I remember I
remember
okay sorry yeah okay we are going right
out the front door to use that uh fuse
we got on fuse yeah the battery sorry
wherever you put it I dropped it should
be on your map somewhere hmm
I should probably pull up my trusty map
what's that noise
sorry got work text I bet it's like
really unrelated to where cats are going
to not much what are you doing well lol
yeah I'm DTF
[Laughter]
no our cats are in and out of the
veterinary stuff I'm sorry fine but I
already hear that maybe shouldn't
[ __ ] make fun of me next time listen
you're the one who made her really gross
off-putting jokes let's be fair it's hot
in here a sec I have this like I mean I
have like all these items I think the
battery is like here damnit oh he's
working on the fan I let me see what we
got going on here and then I wonder I
just want to see yeah I got to I got to
gravestones yeah I feel that I got two
gravestones and I have 15 bullies a full
heal she's on caution so I need be
careful with her 13 spare bullies and
six Grenada's he doesn't have very much
he's got 16 bullets and sick small talks
I don't anticipate that I'm gonna need
the grenades and she's full should I
drop that off well I could keep it
because he has three slots open I think
you are right in your assessment that
you won't need a grenades or any crazy
heavy weaponry ok so I'm gonna leave put
down all weaponry I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave the grenade launcher them
so that should be here cool and then I
need to figure out where we're going so
we can't get through that door yet isn't
it you're going out to the main outdoors
no you're going to the main lobby and
then outside Oh a front door that all
right so back whence we came youtube.com
/ GameSpot that's us you guys live right
now yeah Greg Miller and Alana are in
the studio
I haven't seen a lot on a very long time
and I see I see Greg at almost every
event but yeah when I was on I did kind
of funny recently yeah that's right you
did the games games daily games daily
GameSpot daily u swot daily on kind of
funny
yeah and then uh then the bomb cast this
week and as well as Red Dead radio we've
been they've been just like pimping me
out to whoever will pay the highest it's
no we're recording city episode eight
here we go just pulling us up for some
future reading okay okay so we're going
outside remember there's nothing out
here last time you came out there were
dogs or some [ __ ] out here
you're imagining that there were dogs
yes
press the beaten oh wait
if anybody's wondering throughout the
episode why I'm looking up here it's
because there's a second monitor someone
set up so I could see it up there
I prefer to look down here but there's
also one up there and right here people
think I was oh yeah that new monitor is
interesting I should take a photo of
like the behind the scenes of this room
because there's like this camera
obviously and then there's a monitor
this is where what games that's what
we're looking and then you cheat over
here so this is where we game this is
where we Gaiman this is where we cheatin
and then there's a new gaming up here
too mostly cheatin oh [ __ ] don't look up
my dukes Duke so ok interesting oh you
were right about the dog it was a Boston
Terrier I'm alright so they have to
separate so I'm going to switch people
I'm gonna put him on the lift II will it
work with him on the left is it too much
I went out Roger I don't I don't know
well yeah I could call if he can go I
would agree bye yep
so you want tall dark macchiato with a
twist of silver cinnamon okay I'll give
it see ya okay we're going to Duncan not
Dunkin Donuts anymore so you think she's
safe down here
I hope not she sucks just kidding yeah
oh wait I don't want his Molotov
equipped it's gonna bend that and I
quipped that he does not have a lot of
bullets so I hope there's some here oh
god wait we've been here this is the
birds yeah
what's different now I wonder
what a letdown I thought I thought this
is gonna be a new area um oh wait am I
supposed to push the box yeah I'm an
idiot well down down the stairs so
earlier this was up here like this and
we couldn't do anything with it so I
just have to put Stan on topic with
Billy and have Rebekah bring it back
down okay sorry
it makes it makes sense now it's like
but the lift I thought dude was supposed
to lift us I think would have made more
sense we have such a big break between
episodes
cuz you saw that it was good awful noise
have you ever heard of that statue are
you ever like in an elevator and you're
like yeah that's the noise yes I have I
use a elevator sound at night dun dun
dun dun dun dun dun dun that way you
want me to join in you Suzie L 1979 said
well I'm looking I'm investigating like
put it off push it off this cliff that's
an option and then I'll go over here and
I'll see what's over here like what I'm
looking for is like is there a place
alright climb over the fence there you
go I need to be higher yeah you should
be over that fence I think okay then
there's also a fence on this side
so which fence do we want to climb over
is Wayne do see I'm saying
like there's two fancies I don't think
you want to climate fan so it's bad info
something on top of one of those pillars
I think sometimes they're shiny let me
see what's shiny I see it it's right
here must be a tablet hey I found your
Zune you lost what app do you think he's
into head space or instacart it's
probably like an app for people who've
been to prison like Prizzi's where you
can like meet other inmates and like
keep up after you cons hey what were you
in for I killed this person on their
first date oh hell yeah you wanna go on
a date this doesn't feel like I'll still
be tall enough but I'm gonna do it
anyway
oh is it it's against the wall it's a
classic marry mistake here push the box
alright maybe I need to push it even
further it's annoying if it's not get on
your tippy there we go
it's the third one sweet yeah it is
sweet we're like getting there man
so let's recruit get over your dumb-dumb
so now we're gonna put it in there and I
assume a door will open the one that's
red up there if that's the case then
we'll go through that door
[Music]
Luzi all 1979's Knievel's always a great
way to end my Saturday night thanks guys
thank you I hope the show never ends and
you go through other sea horses as well
and Misha outlast evil didn't help those
all sound good oh my god we like barely
can continue playing this like it just
never ends because we have DLC and we
have like another one coming out next
year I feel like we'll just always be
playing Resident Evil Alison Shearer who
was asking for a shout out I was
anniversary I apologize yeah anniversary
or birthday for Sam Shearer guys you
should have seen Sam face we heard the
shout out he was so happy so so much we
love you and Mary you're right it's a
Boston Terrier his name is Walter he has
his own Facebook if you want to follow
him he's under Walter Rooney do and we
love your nog so adorable yes we've what
were you guys to play the Silent Hill
series that's awesome I want to see more
photos of Walter oh and then Samaritan
it's Sam capital I said thanks babe for
having Mike and Mary should give me a
shout-out doesn't I surprised quick
plugging your dog's Facebook page that's
ridiculous and then Nathan Shepherd our
good friends that fame will strip him of
its innocence hashtag keep Walter pure
there's so much behind the scenes going
on with Walter I know I like I also
people always ask me like what Simone's
Instagram is and I'm like he doesn't
have one because one I don't know if he
like should and - I like use it for my
own self needs so I don't know if you
saw this are born Nathan Shepards
I've set up a Knievel discord server
with a link to a polling forum you can
use to submit your choice suggestion
after the next possible can evil
playthrough Wow
that your voice be heard I want to go
check us out now check it out is this
court that's not my phone so a building
like fell into the water
yeah are you aware of this I heard it
okay so what makes sure that in all of
your chat communications that you're
like aware of what's about to go down
because I certainly do not I hope it's
not dogs
I hear stuff yeah I hear men it's bats
okay it's bats bats do attack us right
yes go your map
a bunch of readies I don't think I have
any keys hopefully I find one down here
okay here we go
whoo ominous well don't stop there
bathroom we're boating stressful dark
spoopy
Oh
Oh looks like someone's gonna stay out
here all right it's gonna be the girl
this is what we've decided I think at
least the bats don't come in here I'll
go yeah actually he'll go is there stuff
back here no looks like I can go back
there but I can
I just want to like survey the area [ __ ]
this animal so hard I don't like it no
super dangerous nothing good happens
back here I promise you that this is
where you go to die locked
what about you okay well good because
that area sucks no lights nothing
alright babe stay back here check it out
look at these door handles it's very
fancy cuz you were working I'm not
working I'm looking up the discord
server what's that noise oh my god
you're the worst guide ever
[Music]
it's an altar
despite its aura of divinity you can't
help but sell send something ominous
about it hmm
I have discord good for you I feel like
I'm going really far into this rabbit
hole no dogs no dogs no dogs no dogs no
dogs [ __ ] neither of us have a shotgun I
okay it's a safe room they're not that
far back away from you oh my god is that
statue a naked woman putting a sword
down her throat oh yeah Wow and the
lights so perfectly grazing her torso
and breast Isla jeez ah I just feel like
ladies never get good busts of men you
know solid bun work and stuff
our time will come alright just posting
this court server awesome I don't want
to save I feel like it's a little early
to save do you concur yes I would say
hold off okay I'm gonna pick these up
but I'm not going to take them just so
that they're logged so I have three new
ribs which is great because I think I
was really actually running out I knew I
had one more but like wasn't enough for
me so I think yeah you're in good shape
okay I always get worried about running
out kind of stuff oh no is it fats it's
that's a big fat how big is that that
it's big the scale is off it's hard to
tell do you think this is a mall cop
scenario or a gun scenario oh it's big
oh it's pretty big okay I ran out of the
room to think about it huh I don't have
a shotgun on me I mean yeah you
definitely want
[Music]
so I have a regular handgun and I have
malt hops which I really think are for
the other that's not gonna do it
I can leave yeah you could leave can I
leave it go like you might even eat
grenade launcher if it's a boss thing
let me I don't know how much eat too
much but I can check I mean I put the
right track it hasn't been that long why
don't I just try to see if I could leave
ya giant bat Wow again a large version
of a regular creature cool alright I got
it
good thing he's easy to dodge good thing
he's an idiot bat
have you ever seen like videos of baby
bats eating bananas they're so cute way
bats are like super cute there's certain
things that I like naturally don't enjoy
what do you think foreign aid launcher
then I don't want to use it if I don't
need it but it's a giant bat it's a
grenade launcher grenades oh I am out of
space I will leave these shotgun shells
maybe over here it will let me I was
right
oh sorry that's you this is stuff oh
wait get those rounds Mike um I'm gonna
drop off an item first okay just so I
have more space right like I'm out of
space I'm out of space where am I you're
yeah you're there it's just they threw
the Lemonier monkeys at you what the
[ __ ] cuz the grenade launcher still in
the main lobby is that what you're doing
no but this room they said I couldn't
put any more [ __ ] in it for God's sakes
they're just adding monkeys tonight just
give me a second I'll have to put it
where the bats are is extremely
inconvenient just trying to kill this
giant bat my goodness alright okay
alright but don't you want oh okay
you're not gonna kill me I'm sure just
you needed to drop enough off so you can
pick up the grade exactly you're on the
trolley I prefer a cable car well only
for five years so you're not a local you
haven't earned the right to say that to
me never said I would shut your mouth
you invader um also he doesn't have a
heel so if this bat is like dead one
handgun rounds not doing anything
worthwhile like you're honestly better
off firing off a round with a pistol
right now and reloading yeah yeah I'm
gonna use it I'm gonna shoot it no I
will shoot that I need all those
grenades my grenade launcher has
grenades in it it's got six okay but and
it's got another six alright fine you're
angry angry I'm just frustrate and wrong
filled with the worst combination napalm
yeah I'm good and then I'll just I'll
grab this he'll just in case the bat
like is like aggro I'm sure it's fine
though and then so we'll start with
these ladies that sound good okay
and we'll see how it goes here we go
gonna kill a giant bat today which me am
I gonna be today
I like that he's like what rhymes with
today today nice-lookin [ __ ] she
Rebecca chillin no I wasn't looking at
her I'm watching rewind she's like I'm
so bored monsters wait until he flops
swaps down a [ __ ] alright
sorry oh no oh my god he picked me up oh
my god
Ewing Oh pick me up yeah he's not down
on my level
yeah
forget it yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you are you
watching that
yeah Jeremy try aiming up and you're
just not adjusting your aim once it's
cruising I thought
[ __ ] a resonable seven all over shut up
oh [ __ ] I'm on danger this is bad
come this way
yes where he doesn't have a risk he's
more room to scoot down
I've experienced such problematic bats
got him once Jesus Christ oh now those
are out just keep moving
also there's a lot of bats don't worry
about them
oh you got him again I'm [ __ ] done I
am NOT fine
but
next one it only took ages that could
have gone better but you did it yeah so
that you figured out at the end I think
that you still needed to be aiming up
even if he was low do you feel like you
want to wipe are you fine because I
think you're I don't know what do you
recommend I'm on danger I went I'm going
I went through two full [ __ ] heels
and 12 grenades god bless it
what watch you could restart lo keem I
feel like I'll take a while
you got the tap no you just get the
tablet really quick and then burn all
the [ __ ] upstairs a few more things you
really didn't do much I think it'd be
worth in a long run what a trash
performance well you got it down now
zero we have to do the box again too
I just realized it's actually like
longer than I thought know if that was
worth it yeah what nothing Carothers
Macintosh actually alright I know what
I'm doing so I'm just gonna like hammer
through this last episode if we had
known we probably could have brought the
battery the battery here that's alright
it won't take very long it's just it's
just frustrating cuz I'm gonna be honest
with you although I did learn I all I
also felt like a lot of that battle was
like whatevs like random in a sense
where I don't feel that confident yeah
so here's a thing that I learned that
might be worth the wipe remember that
guy was like you definitely want this
thing in the room it's the hookshot
but that's just you don't need that for
the fight it's that the hole he breaks
in the wall becomes the way you get into
the auditorium at which point you need
to hook shot after you kill the bat so
it has no value to have the hook shot in
this room it has value it's just a bless
backtracking later I'm just saying like
I could put the hook shot in the room
right now no it's more for like um yeah
it's more for just like a quality of
life things you have to go as far back
making Shepherd [ __ ] bats x3 mollies
a day keeps a Marcus away statistics to
the playthrough thus far only three
deaths 79 kill does a white count as a
death I guess it does yeah well I don't
know
she looks so dumb when she goes
downstairs um she dies on 14 health
recoveries 10 saves 11
hi all right so just gonna push on
through here try to do this as quick as
possible
each off a piece may said Halloween can
evil costume ideas for Mike Romanow
Ramon Salazar from RE for tofu from re -
that dope Albert Wesker from re 105 the
merchant from re for moist barrel of
[ __ ] from revelations - what can you
google that I think I
I'd like to know more oh it's something
I share he says I think out of the way
you idiot you idiot
I think it's Moira burden says describes
the situation as a moist barrel box and
she says what the [ __ ] was that it's
funny doing this through their different
perspectives no keep pushing this box
you but push it
it's really not that long and I'm
prepared now I feel like it's he taller
than her where she can't get this that
would be interesting probably I'm gonna
let's test it let's find as much value
and this wife as possible
as my grandma always said all right
[Music]
are you both full I kind of want the
hookshot in this circular room it's not
like a large reason I just feel like it
would be a good call I hate that like
always stuffy
sick feeling where like no matter what
you do you just kind of like you're
never fully clear you never can breathe
you just want to breathe I've breathed
in ages I miss breathing she's gonna get
rid of that why can't I give it to him
how far away are they they're like super
close bunch of dollars
and then you pick up those grenades in
the other room and then you're good all
right we're getting there
not a big deal you guys not like for a
general sense of like don't watch me go
down the stairs and my dukes I feel like
he's always objectifying me it is like
creepy well he's earned it you don't sit
through a tattoo like that expecting to
not be objectified all right so the
whole building
very phallic goes down into the water
okay so people always say feel like
instead of penis-shaped yeah why is that
you think so weird
Oh balls I did it again all right um
she doesn't know she doesn't need to
come oh wait yes she does mom okay I
forgot there's a stepping stone she has
to step on I forgot I forgot about the
stone toads forgot about this time
watch out for the bats girl
could you steer her in there with
let's split up Roger see you [ __ ] oh
you idiot just making my life so
difficult alright okay so there's a safe
room in here so I'm gonna leave the
pucks in here like I did last time I
don't have a need for the shotgun shells
as of now so I'm also gonna leave those
behind but I'm gonna start off with the
napalm grenades this time do you think
those are better yeah he was like yeah
all right oh [ __ ] I forgot to give him
health marry
I forgot to get health
you know
is it back in the white room or whatever
was I thinking
I'm just gonna she's got health on her
so I'll just go to her and get get her
help like it's
it's like a little annoying but it's
totally functional what other bosses can
I expect from this game you know like
giant B are you [ __ ] kidding me did
you see that he like wouldn't run
forward yes I loved it
just got a little nip right before even
left immediately hurt all right give me
your heel because I'm dumb
no I hate her stay there on that tile
while I kill this bat
we're like a rut dumb huh all right here
we go
okay here we go
oh I got you on the first [ __ ]
yeah got him I did but I'd also died
okay you got me it was like a mutual get
up scenario here already doing better
though and I'm also still fine good
night
get a regular bat stop picking me up
it's very rude I have more luck on what
I do it's about to pick me up isn't he I
miss sake
oh god don't pick me up
it's gonna put me in danger I hate this
fight a lot yeah it's really bad game
design to make you do a fight like this
with controls of that [ __ ] stop [ __ ]
alright see I'm pointing at the bat
oh my god I forgot him this time
it's resident evil 3 all over again but
with bats yeah they suck I can't believe
that happened I was on caution and when
one bat hit me I must have been on
danger yeah I think maybe you should
keep moving so those little bats don't
just swarm around you constantly the
problem is like when I'm trying to point
at him I pointed the closest bat yeah so
that's probably why you gotta move to
the other side of the room so they oh my
god we have to do this [ __ ] again it's
ok I can I'll read some comments or some
cheese I don't want to do this again we
should not have white that was a mistake
I would have gladly eaten all those
grenades and 2 Health's to not do this a
third time ah that sucks
[ __ ]
I should have left this ink in the other
place it's like I learned nothing ever
so Rebecca throws molotovs faster and
more accurately than Billie apparently
really don't pick up pick up pick up
don't let the game get to you man I'm
tilted
I don't like redoing things a hundred
times I can't believe that I died to
that stupid bat it's very frustrating
most uninteresting part of this game is
moving boxes and that's what everyone
gets to enjoy three times this episode
maybe more no no more my foot I will
kill this bat I'm not dealing with that
bats dying I felt like I was doing
better
Elwin also alternates between enemies
when aiming l1 does what alternates
between enemies when aiming o so I can
like pick the enemy I want to aim at I
mean it's not a long process it's just
like I'm in like a tedious process yeah
League Ridley says hey Mike and Mary I
were horrible lonely nights on Saturday
and Sunday and canady has been my fuel
for the last year I watch on my lunch
break and scream run along with Mary and
all the jump scares thanks for
everything guys Kamini forever thank you
me that's awesome it's cool too late
you're getting through that Saturday
night shift right now yeah enjoy those
Saturday night shifts you know it's back
and forth you know like sucks like being
alone but sometimes when I work we have
two offices now at switch can I work in
the old office just to be alone there's
nobody in there I like being alone push
this box so help me God Mike should wear
a daisy dukes as punishment for missing
the first oh there's your [ __ ]
Halloween costume some dukes begin
cowboy boots oh my god absolutely oops
maybe not
I was thanks to dr. Phil Angie Regina
phalange all right we are almost at the
bat sequence again so let's get this
stupid thing let's get down all right so
we're gonna go to the observatory now
don't forget I'm going to bring health
I'm going to use it liberally all over
my supple body yeah extra on the TAT
harvest cuz you don't want to have any
kind of like fading issue harvest oh my
god I need to catch up
I just don't think Coronas are for
chuggins hopefully he has a secret cider
he can pull out no be funny to carry
around a flask full of hard cider I use
I used to work at Hall Hollister's night
shift
now this isn't what you think it is it's
not like I'm like you know working the
front desk at Hollister I was the
[ __ ] as the person who folded the
t-shirts and the jeans and the
underneath so that when you came into
the store the next day it looked like a
brand new store it was terrible job and
I used to bring a flask and like
drink in the bathroom ah not 21 I was a
troubled youth peeing your pants makes
you cool then Mike will be Miles Davis I
think it was just such a boring ass job
I felt like if I didn't do something
like that I would like die it was such a
boring job I drink here all the time no
just kidding
this job is cool but it does five drinks
more at GameSpot than I have at any
other job in my life including twitch
mm-hmm because it games by it was normal
to like work late see it's like I won't
be careful with how I say this you don't
have to but it is likely because you
care about what you cut your work so
much that you'll stay late to make it
better so people end up working late a
lot and to make the time go by if you're
like working until like 8:00 p.m. which
happens all the time
we bought beers so I I drink all the
time
mm-hmm I guess what I'm trying to say is
like it's not like I was like angry or
like you know screws place like I was
happy to do it but beer was like
something that we like decided was the
least they could do because we worked
late all the time
so we used to drink all the time and you
guys have like parties and stuff like
wheat the paid a beer days and oh cool
and third Thursday is like those are all
like beer scenarios sorry I'm just like
going over anything else that I need
I think that's it
alright bat take three you got it
uh-huh
[Music]
I'm not doing this again I'll quaff so
many potions to not like deal with baths
you stay here yeah
those door handles why didn't you
mention them you gotta do better I've
been to this spot three times I know
exactly what's going down this isn't a
good opportunity to catch me off guard
oh my god is that a giant bat how
unexpected oh wait I got a [ __ ] equip
that all right all right here we go
take three I'm going to kill this bat
I'm going to kill this bag I'm going to
kill this bat alright my spot
shut up I'm not oh my god look up
do it yeah okay move to start moving
little bats wait I got a good all right
all right
let me just look at where we're at
because I've only been picked up twice
of course this is how we make these you
do definitely want to like seem
consistent I know you do want to be
moving moving got it
I mean you're lining up good shots stop
touching me you yeah you got him let's
just check how
we actually don't even care oh no I
don't care I want to kill mama yeah one
more like one more stop
what oh Jesus that was a long shot
alright we're not doing this again I
think that stone we should wipe it ha
[ __ ] you good way the end the episode
that's almost an hour
Stella it was weaned every every hero
story needs a villain and that bat has
become the villain of this games I hate
this bat ok in your defense that's a
poorly designed boss fight for a game
with poor controls even in the updated
control ok it looks like you could use
something to get up there we could save
that for next week or does it really
been an hour I'd like to get something
accomplished ok yeah go for it
I don't want to die I think that's my
fear yeah that's the problem
what do you mean I could look ahead to
see if using the hookshot wouldn't put
you in a danger that you might lose the
same I just don't want to like die yet
I could save ya but then you'd save like
toys toward the end of one episode oh my
god
make sure I do a quick bullet I'm
obviously upset
it sounds like this might be a good
place okay let you got you got you
killed the boss does but I don't think
you'll have a save point once you
grapple up there for a long time let me
do this then if nothing else I'm gonna
get some stuff done that would be nice
to get done
that will help me next episode okay I'm
gonna make mall togs
okay I'm gonna organize all my stuff
sounds logical just holy [ __ ] it's
Friday happy Friday thanks Saturday when
people are watching this though
yeah we're recording this the day before
it goes off because somebody decided to
get sick this week spend more time in
bed on Wednesday I ever have in my adult
life I went I woke up at 8:00 felt had a
migraine and sometimes my migraines
trigger a fever because they don't
migraines so bad that my body wants to
fight it off oh my goodness Eva and I
woke up again at 6:00 p.m. and then
slept until 8:00 p.m. and then got up
and played Assassin's Creed Odyssey for
three hours and I went back to bed and
slept until this morning oh my goodness
yesterday when I got it all right so
I've made three more mall tops I think
there was something else I wanted to do
[Music]
he's not gonna need this right now most
likely I'm gonna leave this and then I'm
gonna get the shotgun I think that's the
good one and these shotgun shells she's
on caution so he's gonna need he's gonna
need that okay and now we have 14
shotgun shells which I'm gonna want for
the Monkees I could kill the Monkees
thought you have to like are you going
back there for sure you're not gonna be
back there for a while all right there's
a lot you don't have to go back there
for all right so we've got everything
now that I think we want in Gribben
there's something there's ink ribs new
safe room that we've unlocked oh my god
what a terrible episode I am so sorry
it was entertaining for me it was all
bat related I can't believe I died -
that bad again I made it
they're both kind of hurt we're both on
coffee on here it's not great it's not
my best episode yeah about it way it's
not as bad as Brazzaville three was that
was just continual humiliation three
yeah my nemesis I think they just spent
all of it like holding my breath dying
like feeling bad about myself leaving me
to pick up the pieces of my brilliant
jokes and endearing charisma I was in a
bad mood because I was constantly like
stressed about dying this is the nature
oh don't worry it's gonna bring this
back up okay this is where the episode
started to go south look away look away
I feel in general my parents texted me
this is true what your parents thank you
the rump is coming here on Friday I
don't know how we're gonna get you at
the airport and I was like what's the
rump and they said Donald Trump sorry I
don't know if it was a typo if that's
what they call him
probably a typo rump okay and everybody
thank you so much for watching resin
knievel another episode we finally got
through that bat and we will be back
next Saturday as usual thank you to
everybody who always joins us and
crawled the tips and for setting up that
discourse server actually let me pull
out really quick if you want to go to
the discord the resident Knievel
community discord server
Nathan Shepard set it up on discord it
is discord GG forward slash 6k D capital
u DHN and you can see it will I'll have
our YouTube producer pin the comments we
hope to share something - yeah I'll
tweet it if you follow both tweet it
follow us on Twitter if you don't but
anyway thanks so much for joining and we
will see you soon mama speaking I'm
working on my remember when I used to
like bats
yeah it was like 40 minutes ago